results rolling in from high stakes
midterm elections in the United States
Republicans now have the lead in the
race for the house and the Democrats are
one seat ahead in the battle for control
of the Senate they've edged into the
leaders Democrat John Federman wins the
key Senate race of Pennsylvania beating
celebrity Dr Mehmet Oz voters have been
choosing lawmakers for a third of Senate
seats and the entire House of
Representatives
the Republicans lead the race for the
house but the vote appears closer than
polls predicted with the Republicans
hoped for Red Wave failing to
materialize
and let's see what the numbers say
starting with the Senate and the seats
that are not up for grabs in this
election
and now if you add in those newly
decided seats you can see at this point
the Democrats with 48 seats so far
versus 47.
with vice president Kamala Harris able
to cast high-breaking votes the
Republicans would need 51 for a majority
and if we look at the house
162 out of the 435 seats have so far
gone to the Democrats at 192 to the
Republicans but of course for both
Chambers it's still too early to draw
any conclusions with razor thin margins
in key races a full picture may not be
available for days if not weeks
let's bring in DW correspondent Michiana
kufner who's in Washington DC for us
what about this fetterman flip
it's quite something the Democrats
managed to flip that particular senate
seat actually increasing their lead in
the Senate right now the Republicans now
need to gain two seats to turn the
Senate around and that is something that
few had predicted mehmed us had
continued to gain ground on John
Federman particularly after John
fetterman the Democrat candidate
suffered a stroke early on in their
campaign he didn't perform well in a
televised debate many had advised them
simply not to do it and mimit Oz a very
well recognized face here in the United
States
and really someone who caught up to John
fetterman in recent weeks so that will
be quite a surprise it's quite a setback
and it makes it very tangible that that
red tsunami that the Republicans had
declared would happen simply is nothing
like a tsunami yes this is still
potentially a wave but it is a much more
intricate much more complex pattern that
is playing out here tonight
and a big win though for Rhonda Santos
we were reporting that earlier this
morning
yes Rwanda Santos this is absolutely
huge last time the first time he was
elected governor that was largely thanks
to very prominent backing from none
other than Donald Trump or the then
president this time he did it off his
own accord despite all because of a
mounting rivalry that he is having with
Donald Trump over the prospect of who
could be on the ticket on the
presidential ticket in two years time
Donald Trump had ridiculed him during
his campaigning for others in recent
weeks spoken of Ron de sanctimonious and
Ron DeSantis time and time again ducking
the question whether he would run in
2024 I think that we're seeing something
of an internal rivalry becoming an
internal race on who could be on the
ticket in two years time for those
presidential elections with everybody
pretty much expecting Donald Trump to
declare
um over the course of the next week on
the 15th he said he would make a very
important announcement what are some of
the other results that have stood out to
you with polls now closed
well it's interesting that we have seen
some history in the making here
um we have seen in Maryland just around
the corner from here West Moore elected
the first black governor in
Massachusetts we're seeing the first
openly gay woman elected as governor and
the first generation Z House member was
elected in Florida and we're also seeing
a pattern that the Republicans are
indeed gaining ground but this is a much
much tighter night than any pollster had
predicted well Michelle before we get on
to policy and voter turnout let's have a
listen into what some voters believe
have been the key issues going into
these midterms
uh you know the economy is is rigged for
the wealthy and uh it's uh you know and
if we don't change that
um you know we're sunk we've got to do
something to reverse the inflationary
trend
that uh you know and the Democrats are
spending out of control Congress is
spending out of control
that needs to come back in line
um honestly the abortion rights are
really big right now as a woman I feel
like it's really important to protect
our health and those who can't help
themselves it's just you know better for
all the women who can have that right to
Health Care
well the number one thing is the
pro-life issue it's been disgusting
watching Joe Biden Proclaim himself as a
Catholic and not standing for pre-born
citizens of our nation
um well I like to vote at every election
but I think especially this time you
know it's about Reproductive Rights it's
about the environment it's about
ensuring that everyone you know has an
opportunity to vote Republicans because
I want them to start running this
country like a business like Trump did
okay get us back on track please
a lot of issues there a lot of
enthusiasm but what about voter turnout
Michaela
well voter turn up is notably up we're
still to see concrete figures of the
overall turnout but what was for sure is
that some 40 million had already cast
their early ballots with a postal some
were able to appear in person uh days
before election day that was more than
the total of the last elections so a
high turnout and that does historically
tend to favor the Democrats although
midterms also historically are a time to
remind the president's party usually of
who holds the power and that is we the
people so usually there's always a
setback for the party of the sitting
president
for us in Washington DC thank you very
much for the analysis
well one of the most watched contests in
this election is in the state of Arizona
widely seen as one of the closest races
for governor initial results saw
Democrat Katie Hobbs Take the Lead
reflecting mail ballots returned ahead
of election day but her lead over
Republican Kary lake is expected to
narrow considerably as ballots cast in
person on an election day accounted lake
is a former television news anchor and
first-time candidate considered a rising
star on the right
she's echoed former president Donald
Trump's false claims that the 2020
election was stolen and she continues to
question the electoral process
indicating she will only accept the
result if she wins
we
we cheaters and Crooks think anything
different don't let them doubt don't let
them put doubt in you
we have a movement
we have a movement and we know it did
you feel it did you feel that movement
the Washington bureau chief Ines Paul is
following the race in Arizona in the
capital Phoenix I asked her what that
statement tells us about Lake's campaign
she delivered
a party which was
me her big Vic party here in Phoenix
Arizona but it turned out to be a very
very difficult a night for Kerry Lake
and therefore it took her like three or
so hours to come out and address her
fans and I mean she did it again she
just repeated uh the big lie she said
that's not in our quote we were just
playing by the earlier in Her speech
that the 2020 election was written that
she is or can't declare winner now
because again uh the whole system is not
correct and you one shouldn't just one
should not trust the election outcome so
that's her main message she's done that
before she kind of declared uh even
before election night if she wouldn't be
the winner of these elections this
cannot be uh the fair and correct result
just how close is the result going to be
where you are
it is close
you know we have to be a little bit
careful with that and Michelle talked
about that earlier on why is that here
in Arizona the vote in ballot was really
high one third or so of all voters uh
turned in their ballots before today and
normally or these early voters are
rather Democratic than Republican these
votes have been counted yesterday so
they were out immediately after the
polls closed and all the Republicans who
went out vote today these votes are
still counted so it's really far too
early to take to declare uh Katie Hopps
the legit winner of these elections here
in Arizona we might have a very
different picture in a couple of hours
and it is of course if you do win it's
easy enough to say okay I've won if you
don't win it's easy enough to say the
votes rigged uh how widespread is this
idea or concept of election integrity
when we're told Time and Again by
officials in in in so many of these
races that everything is going by the
book and when mistakes are made they're
even making that very well known to the
public and and correcting those mistakes
when it comes to a machine breaking down
or something happening
oh really trans
problems with printers but indeed that
is a huge problem Michaela also talked
about that some 150 or so outspoken
election deniers God voted in office
today and that is huge because it's not
only about the governors it's not uh
only about the Senators it's also about
different lower levels judges who by the
end of the day are going to decide who
has won the 2024 presidential elections
are declared outspoken election deniers
and that is a huge problem for a a
democracy when deniers by the end become
the verifiers so uh this is something
many people here in the United States
are concerned about
so it is are there any signs yet as to
how these midterms are going to shape
that 2024 race
well it depends
Japan election deniers really will be in
place Kerry lake is one of them if she
becomes the governor of Arizona she
definitely will play an important role
but I think what we already can say even
so uh so many results are not in here
putting out pure lies being an outspoken
election denier
doesn't prevent many many Republicans
from voting for you because they care
more about the inflation more about
abortion laws more about lgbtq plus
rights and that is a new Dynamic here in
the United States
reporting on the new dynamic in the
United States from Phoenix Arizona thank
you very much
ndw's William glucrafter is part of our
team covering these U.S midterms what
questions are you asking yourself
William as these results rolled in I'm
asking myself a lot of questions this
morning as we should be because we don't
have the results and there's so much
left to know we're still counting votes
and we're going to be counting votes for
for days possibly we have to remember
that states and counties run elections
in America so thousands of counties
thousands of elections are really taking
place today and they all have their own
rules they have all their own rules
about when votes are counted how votes
are counted so we're never when it might
take a very long time to get a complete
picture of both the house and the Senate
of course at State levels Governors
State legislatures this kind of thing
what it's going to come down to is there
are many important issues we've seen
this in the polling data for months now
uh is it going to be inflation that's
going to really be what's pushing people
to the polls is it going to be uh
abortion or lack thereof is it going to
be the guns issue is it going to be the
question of the very foundations of
democracy in the United States what one
of these issues or multiples of these
issues is going to be pushing more
voters to what side to be voting for
their parties where that voter
enthusiasm is those are my biggest
questions and that we're gonna have to
wait for a lot more data to be coming
out what about this red wave that
Republicans were forecasting uh do you
see that building up or fizzling out so
far we're seeing that it's not quite a
dramatic night for Republicans uh that
Republicans certainly are hoping for
that of course history shows that the
party not in power has a big a big win
on on a midterm night given everything
going on in the world with inflation
with the war in Ukraine with high prices
with uh questions about democracy uh one
side or the other
um you do have to ask yourself why
aren't Republicans doing even better yes
it is likely that Republicans will take
the house they could even take the
Senate and then for all intents and
purposes it doesn't matter by how much
they have power power is power and they
can then dictate the the terms of
American government man but it the
question is
should they be struggling as much as
they are should they be doing even
better given all the factors in
Republicans favor both again
historically speaking and just
everything happening right now in the
present moment well well that's it so
what do you reckon do you reckon a whole
lot of Democrats have turned out a whole
lot of younger voters have turned out uh
and have realized this is a really
important election for us we've been
seeing a lot of voter enthusiasm on both
sides really
um going into this election remember uh
as we saw in 2020 Democrats tend to vote
more early vote by mail vote absentee
whereas Republicans tend to vote on the
day and as I said earlier depending how
a state or counties Count Their votes we
might not have a full picture of
you know the more democratic votes the
more Republican votes in what order they
get counted
um but really these elections America is
a divided country they have people have
two choices republican or democrat or
don't vote or or throw your vote away so
these elections are decided on the
margins it's not a very satisfying uh
win for Democrats or Republicans when
you realize you may be squeaked by with
50.1 percent of the vote but that's
where these elections are decided what
could be the Tipping Point then
uh the Tipping Point as I said is gonna
be what drives people out what has
gotten people to the polls uh what are
people most worried about what's that
going to be is it going to be the
economy because I mean it's it usually
always is yeah I mean as Bill Clinton
said it's the economy stupid right if
you want if you want to keep people on
your side you want people uh affording
their their food affording gas being
able to have a good job feeling like
they're comfortable and secure the
economy is obviously much more than
foreign policy often on the front mind
the front of minds of of Voters William
glue Croft thank you very much for your
analysis
or the world is certainly watching the
U.S midterms aware that the outcome
could well impact many issues including
U.S foreign policy the war in Ukraine is
a concern for American voters and some
are questioning how much longer the U.S
should support Ukraine's fight against
Russia
Russia's war against Ukraine is one the
U.S has not been able to look away from
Americans have already sent more than 60
billion dollars worth of assistance into
this war zone Democrat President Joe
Biden has promised to continue to do all
it takes to defend Ukraine sovereignty
As Americans head to the polls in these
midterm elections U.S Congress is
expected to turn more Republican and the
big question everybody is asking is what
impact that will have on U.S assistance
to Ukraine and other allies well the
answer depends on who you ask there will
be enough support no matter who controls
uh which house and given President Biden
still in the white house so I I am quite
confident that very very strong support
will continue for Ukraine yet one
prominent Republican started sending a
very different signal ahead of the
election Kevin McCarthy is the top
Republican in the House of
Representatives he says he believes
Americans would no longer be willing to
write a blank check to Ukraine in the
face of a biting recession back home
after all the soaring prices of gas food
and housing topped the list of worries
for ordinary Americans Democrats fear
that a republican majority in Congress
could soon make Ukraine a domestic
bargaining chip but Paul so more than
two-thirds of Americans back U.S
assistance to Ukraine even if there is a
republican majority in the house and or
the Senate I think perhaps the
experience of working together so
closely
and so confidentially and with so much
trust on sanctions might perhaps help to
defuse
um
tensions over trade protectionism in
general
or over the larger question of how to
deal with malignant Chinese behavior in
the trade and Technology Realm I'm going
to say I'm cautiously optimistic on that
warnings that China may try to invade
Taiwan rather sooner than later could
become the next test for the west and
for America's willingness to pay a price
for Global Leadership
the reaction here in Europe I'm joined
by our Brussels correspondent Bob
reviews
let's start with you what will Brussels
make of the result so far
Brussels has been waiting and that goes
for the European governments of course
with baited breasts for the results of
those midterm elections and and now
there might be something like a slight
relief about this not being the foretold
Red Wave the Republican wave that will
sort of sweep everything away that has
so far been done in Washington by
President Biden and thrown him into a
total lame duck in the second half of
his presidency but of course what we
just saw about help and support for
Ukraine is very valid and Europeans know
that if the United States reduce their
support for Ukraine they will be pushed
to do more and that is Again difficult
because many European governments will
have to go through this winter of
discontent also with Rising inflation
gas prices Energy prices and so on and
so forth that is one big aspect and the
other big aspect is of course fears for
measures against climate change if there
would be a strong Republican presence
now in Washington then of course what
cop 27 at the moment is talking about in
Egypt might as well not be worth the
paper it's written on those are I think
the two biggest concern in Europe
Benjamin in your view what will
politicians waking up here in Berlin
think
so there's definitely concerns
especially about the election deniers
and that's something that Michael linked
the transatlantic coordinator in
Germany's foreign office said that this
is a test and it will also depend on if
people and if those who are elected to
the houses and everyone in the society
already accepts the results the
transatlantic partnership between the US
and Germany is as strong as it was since
the end of the Cold War and that's an
idea that Germany has said repeatedly
not only during the trip of the German
foreign minister annalena but also last
week when the G7 foreign ministers me to
to show that the transatlantic Alliance
regardless of who wins this race of who
wins the midterms in both Chambers will
remain strong and that it's so important
for the German side to have the US on
their side not only when it comes to
Ukraine something that Barbara mentioned
when it comes to climate change but also
when it comes to trade
Barbara if Biden and his Democrats lose
both houses what will that mean for
Europe
it means of course that foreign policy
will become much more difficult it also
means that what Ben just refer to that
is the idea of a real Boon for our third
authoritarian governments in Europe and
we are not innocent on that front look
at Italy we don't know yet where that
country is going we have of course
Victor Orban in Apollo in in Hungary and
we have the Polish government which is
however somewhat tied to its support for
Ukraine here and and can't really make
any big moves in in that direction but
of course the transatlantic relationship
having returned throughout the last two
years to a better State than it was for
for many years and people feeling great
relief European governments and of
course institutions has brought in
Brussels feeling great relief about that
if all this should be overthrown a much
more difficult times will come and it
feels like a crisis that we're
experiencing all of us worldwide is
being topped off another by another
crisis that now will be coming over from
the United States and that is not
entirely welcome so difficult times for
all that much is clear what do you
reckon you mean um what will it mean for
Germany if Republicans do take control
of both houses
Germany is quite sure and Berlin knows
that even though they have for many
domestic issues during this campaign
this will shape this will put the tone
on U.S foreign policy for the next two
years and of course a lame duck so if
the Democrats lose the majority in both
Chambers they will mean there will be
more difficult for the transatlantic
relationships between Germany and
between the U.S something that Germany
has said that there is now a
transatlantic momentum and that we have
to seize that that's something what
German foreign also stressed during a
visit to the U.S in August showing how
important it is to tackle these issues
together and especially now considering
the winter is coming with many problems
here in Europe not only when it comes to
security concerns but also when it comes
to dependency of oil and gas and looking
for other energy Partnerships
here in Berlin and Brussels thank you
very much to both of you